control and hitman 3 are coming to
nintendo's switch
no man's sky gets free next gen upgrades
and all of the backwards compatibility
for xbox series x
and s is complete i'm lucy let's jump
into the news
nintendo released a surprise mini direct
today and there were some big
announcements
first control ultimate edition is
available to play on nintendo switch
right now yes really this is the first
game to offer ray tracing on switch
but you can choose between 30 frames per
second with ray tracing on
or 60 frames per second without it the
ultimate edition also includes both of
the game's expansions the foundation and
awe
so how does it work well this is the
cloud version of control
so you'll actually be streaming it to
your switch this requires a nintendo
switch online account
and a high speed internet connection
which you'll have to test
before you can make the purchase this
isn't the first switch game that streams
from the cloud resident evil 7 was
available in this form in japan
hitman 3 will also have a cloud version
on switch when it launches in january
we've got all the info from this mini
direct over on gamespot.com including
the news that bravely default 2 has been
pushed to next year
no man's sky may released a few years
ago now but it's still getting free
next-gen upgrades
for the brand new consoles when they
launch next month no man's sky will be a
launch title so that means it'll come
out on november 10th on series x
and s and november 12th on ps5 you can
also play the psvr version on ps5 but be
aware that that's technically just the
backwards compatible ps4 version
enhancements include better textures
bigger base building
multiplayer sessions with up to 32
players and cross play support for the
next gen consoles
ps5 and series x play the game at 60
frames per second and in 4k
on series s you can choose between
running at 60 frames per second
or have an improved resolution the ps5
also has extra enhancements
the multi-tool reacts to the dual
sensor's adaptive triggers and the game
has 3d audio
and of course for more next-gen coverage
keep your eyes peeled to generation next
every friday
this week we're answering your questions
about the playstation 5.
it's official every backwards compatible
game you've played on your xbox one will
now work
on your xbox series s or x xbox is
jason ronald confirmed via twitter so
you'll be able to jump into your current
xbox library
on day one the one exception to this is
anything that may have required connect
and for a closer look at the new xboxes
check out our unboxings i got to unbox
the xbox series x
and s and both videos should be up on
youtube.com
gamespot and gamespot.com now thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you